was anyone around in your ear saying oh
I wouldn't go there it's it's too much
of a hot topic it's too emotional or did
people cheer you on and say we need this
there were there were mixed feelings in
the beginning there were people that in
the film community that said you never
sell this
you'll never get distribution you
wouldn't go international you wouldn't
do this you wouldn't do that and people
that I didn't know but I would talk
about the project with it and that was
kind of like crushing you know you're
like all come on my project and then
what happened that felt like we got the
support of parents groups we got the
support of churches that wanted to
strengthen marriage we got the support
of the father's rights groups and we got
the support of the feminist groups that
realize it was a system that was broken
it wasn't that parents didn't want to
get along it was that there was a system
that was keeping people from
communicating and that was huge so the
groups were started paying for our
travel fees to go to New York and talk
to people we interviewed police officers
that were on the force for 20 30 years
and were stripped away because they all
of a sudden were being divorced and we
were talking to doctors to lawyers to
judges to legal it you know everybody
that just started coming forward and it
became it got bigger and bigger and
bigger and it didn't really change for
me until I got the first suicide note in
my inbox and I know we're talking about
this and I didn't realize that that was
the point where I didn't know what to do
with that and my I think it was our
editor to say you gotta tell him to call
you and and I reached out an email I
should just call us and we talked for
like a half-hour and he was crying since
I'm gonna send you all my paperwork I
heard you guys are doing this but I'm
killing myself today I've been in the
court for seven years I can't see my
kids I've lost everything Allah
have lost everything and I think that
was like man you know this guy was gonna
kill himself not not including the
people that we already had on camera
that have already died one walked into a
courthouse with a grenade because he
couldn't see his son the other one
walked in with a machine gun this guy
was just about to do himself he wasn't
hurting anybody
you know and I think that that's where I
just said this thing has to survive you
know you get into I got into filmmakers
like I want to be this big Hollywood
star and I'm gonna sell my scripts and
I'm gonna do all that and then that day
it just became real it just was like you
know so I'm sure at that point it was
not about distribution it was more about
like this has to you know I haven't got
any support from as a filmmaker for
distribution it's always been self it's
always been YouTube it's been you know
free videos DVDs whatever we do we try
to raise funds we try to do that and
it's been you know it you're right it
wasn't about you know it was about how
how can we change someone's life and let
them know there is support there's other
people like him you know and he's not a
bad person because he can't pay child
support or he got divorced or you know
he was you know a target of fatherhood
you know or whatever they want to call
it it's just
you